joining us now Harvard Law Professor
Alan dtz uh Professor you are mentioned
in this document you mentioned
repeatedly and very
specifically um it was the allegation
against you was that Epstein forced then
minor Jane do number three to have
sexual relations with you and that also
you were an eyewitness to sexual abuse
of other minors by Epstein uh you have
been out there vigorous ly Defending
Your your name your honor and and
denying these allegations fiercely and I
want to give you a chance now that it's
come out and writing tonight to to get
your
reaction well first of all the woman who
accused me has now stated categorically
that she may have misidentified me
confused me with someone else and these
documents if all the documents are
revealed will prove categorically that
she did misidentify me that I never met
her never heard of her never uh spoke to
her uh and I can prove it by independent
means I have all my travel records I
have all my uh television appearances I
can prove that I couldn't possibly have
been anywhere near any of the people who
were involved in this I was Epstein's
lawyer of course I flew on his plane
with Ken star with uh Roy black with
other lawyers we flew to meetings with
the US attorney with the state attorney
um and so people have to be very careful
about what they're believing and when it
happened for example as soon as epine
was shown to be what he was I ended my
personal association with him completely
but I maintained a legal relationship
with them I represented some of the
worst people in the world and continue
to do so that's my life and of course I
represented FC now the one point I do
want to make is that I understand all
the feminist groups and the radicals who
think this is the worst thing in the
world that anybody ever had any contact
with Jeffrey Epstein where are all those
radical feminists when it comes to the
Hamas rapes of young Jewish girls sexual
abuse beheadings they are quiet they are
silent the incredible hypocrisy of the
me too movement me tooo except if you're
a Jew if uh and I want to have a list of
all the radical feminists who are
pushing hard and I understand that to
get all these names revealed and I want
to know how many of them have ever
actually condemned Hamas for the rapes
that we now know ofur and the murders
that occurred how many have been silent
and how many like the national lawyers
Guild have actually approved of what
Hamas did so let's put this in context
I'm thrilled that all these papers have
come out I urged them I went to court I
asked for everything to come out because
I knew that I had done nothing wrong and
the papers would exculpate me what I
only worry about is that maybe the judge
has withheld certain documents I want to
make sure every single document comes
out including the documents that cast
out on The credibility of some of the
accusers and some of the accused the
public has the right to see everything
and make their own Jud we do not country
in guilt by accusation or guilt by
association but by the way I think that
is fair and I still like you believe
that in the presumption of innocence and
I don't rush the judgment and frankly in
on many Hope High profile cases in this
country this show starting with Richard
juel we've been right we were right
about Duke lacrosse we were right about
uh UVA we were right about Ferguson
Missouri and Freddy gray and Baltimore
because I didn't rush to judgment and
and I had impeccable sources I have
known you for years I don't I don't
really know why you like to defend these
high-profile clients everybody certainly
deserves a defense including Mr Epstein
including OJ Simpson and you and I had
Wars over Bill Clinton back in the day
um sure you've taken on these these
high-profile cases why and do you regret
it at all and did you ever see anything
unored about Mr
repsy I never did and I do regret having
ever met Jeffrey abstein because it uh
caused me the worst few years of my life
when I was falsely accused and I was
cancelled by the 92nd Street y canceled
by Temple Emanuel and then she UL
admitted that she may have confused me
with someone else and so you know things
obviously have gotten a lot better now
of course these Revelations put my name
in the headlines again but I've never
been afraid of that because I have
nothing to be afraid of nothing to be
ashamed of I did nothing wrong um would
I do it again not if I knew I was going
to be falsely accused but if not for
that I represented far worse people I've
represented murderers I've represented
people who have done terrible terrible
things that's an essential part of our
system if I don't do it who will I had
tenure I had an obligation to defend the
most controversial the worst people
sometimes I won sometimes I lost
sometimes I created a plea bargain like
I did in this case by the way Epstein
was furious at me for the ple bargain he
wouldn't pay my fee because he thought I
had done a terrible job because he ended
up going to jail and having to report as
a sex offender the rest of the world
thought it was a sweetheart but that's
what criminal defense lawyers do I'm 85
years old I hope good Lord gives me the
strength to continue to represent the
most despised the most controversial the
most unpopular people in the world look
at the hell I got for representing
Donald Trump I did that and I lost a lot
of my friends and people say to me all
the time oh I understand epy but not
Trump or I understand Trump but not AB
you have to understand that the role of
the criminal defense lawyer is to defend
everybody who's falsely
accused or even truthfully accused yeah
I I think you're going to be the only
one that does have the courage to say no
it's not true and you do make a good
point if there's exculpatory information
that is not released as part of the
information that is being given out by
the judge I think that's unfair to
everybody and that would be unfair to
you uh and if you believe it's
exculpatory uh I think the public should
see that as well Professor thank you I
don't need any more exculpatory material
because the woman has already admitted
that she may have clearly misidentified
me and that's enough for me I'm going on
with my life I'm going to continue to do
what I've been doing for years but thank
you Sean for an opportunity to present
my my case Professor we appreciate your
time as always thank you for being with
us hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere
else